Donald Trump campaigns today in Virginia
and North Carolina he is rejecting
charges from Democrats that his
foundation crossed a line with a
political contribution while Florida's
Attorney General considered suing Trump
University major Garrett is in Cleveland
where Trump spent Labor Day talking
about jobs major good morning good
morning at a county fair just outside of
blue-collar Youngstown Donald Trump and
Mike Pence found a huge crowd very
enthusiastic the ride was a bit rougher
however from Cleveland to Youngstown as
Trump faced questions again on his
immigration policy debate preparation
and Trump University from a Cleveland
restaurant to Ohio's largest county fair
Donald Trump and running mate mike pence
campaigned in democratic northeastern
ohio what about jobs at a morning
roundtable with union workers Trump
turned his attention to China's
perceived diplomatic snub of President
Obama calling his unceremonious exit
from Air Force One a sign of weakness I
have pictures of other leaders of the
cup going there and then coming down
with a beautiful red car and Obama is
coming down a metal staircase on the
same day hillary clinton allowed
reporters to start flying on her
campaign plane Trump summoned reporters
to his private jet for the first time in
months and offered little clarity on his
now wobbly promise to deport
undocumented immigrants who committed no
other crimes I'm not ruling out anything
legal status agreeing to attend all
three presidential debates the
Republican nominee called too much
preparation risky I've seen people do so
much prep work that when they get out
that they can't speak let's say that
Trump also denied his foundation made a
political contribution in order to
discourage Florida Attorney General Pam
Bondi from joining a fraud suit against
Trump University I've just known Pam
Bondi for years I have a lot of respect
for never spoke to about that at all
Bondi solicited the contribution for a
political group that supports hurt in
the end pursued no charges Trump says it
doesn't matter because he's going to win
the Trump University case well not
entirely Trump's charitable foundation
had to pay the IRS a twenty five hundred
dollar penalty Charlie for making and
failing to properly disclose this
contribution thanks major